sake maybe the map coholic beverage we
most associate with Japan and beer is
even more popular there but lately the
country has developed a taste for wine
not just drinking it but making it too
and turns out Japanese women are leading
the way and tracy has more with its
high-tech robots bustling cities and
fast trains Japan often seems ahead of
the curve but when it comes to wine it's
simply trying to catch up my friends
loved wine if my friends don't drink
wine they're not my friends
melinda joe is a writer covering the
food and beverage scene in tokyo but
this is for work of course it's always
for work she says women are the reason
Japan has set a new wine consumption
record every year since 2012 one of the
reasons we see a lot of women drinking
wine is because we see a lot more women
in the workforce with a lot more
disposable income and this idea of like
just getting together with friends and
drinking wine has become you know very
common per capita wine consumption in
Japan has jumped 50 percent since 2006
the average Japanese drinker now sips a
little more than three bottles of wine
per year but that's still a fraction of
the nearly 12 bottles down by Americans
or the whopping 56 bottles the French
consume so why do you think wine was not
a big deal with people here for so long
well because the sake culture was so
strong
younger people see sake as more
old-fashioned and wine is just a little
bit more cosmopolitan this is Japan's
wine country
Yamanashi prefecture with all the
vineyards popping up here it's being
called the Napa Valley of Japan
even though Japanese wine has
historically been considered bottom of
the barrel people never thought like we
will make that great girl Ayana Misawa
is the winemaker at grace vineyard which
her family started in 1923 the grapes
are coming along nicely
this part of Japan gets nearly three
times as much rain as California's Napa
Valley it's so wet and humid they have
to put little grape umbrellas on the
vines so the fruit doesn't grow mold how
hard is it to make wine out here to make
good wine it's a very very difficult in
this climate condition so you could make
a lot of what people might call that
wine but making good wine is hard yeah
good one is hot yeah so it's a good
thing these grapes known as Koshu
literally have a thick skin
grace vineyards wine is now being
exported to 20 different countries and
winning awards tourists are showing up
to sample what is still a novelty
quality Japanese wine why do you think
people are finding that they like this
particular kind of wine japanese fine is
very mysterious it's mysterious yeah who
what's mysterious about it the taste was
so very different from other wines
that's because it's meant to perfectly
pair with equally delicate Japanese
cuisine such as sushi and sashimi for
stores like this dedicated to domestic
vintages the idea of Japanese fine wine
is no longer a joke the attitude towards
Japanese wine has been changing a lot
and the reason behind that is mostly
because the quality has just gotten so
much better in the last 20 years for CBS
this morning Saturday Ben Tracy Tokyo
will have to find some sample what is
serious what make very good Scotch too
by the way
we'll get some of that as well